hi i'm dave travis i'm the test prep
content manager at khan academy it's
especially challenging when you
make a mistake again and again and again
and you know that you did it wrong you
know immediately when you did it that oh
i did that thing again and i need to fix
that i need to go back and fix it and
iron it out and get it smooth and
and there's a
a motto
that i like a lot which is very simple
which is the more you do it the better
you get
and i heard somewhere that you actually
need to do a skill for 10 000 hours
if you really want to get good and
that's true with
martial arts it's true with
ceramics it's true with
writing it's through the language it's
through a musical instrument if you want
to get good at something it takes time
and you need to
be patient with yourself you need to
trust yourself and trust that your brain
can do these things
and just because you bump up against
a frustration or a challenge
that's an opportunity to grow it's an
opportunity to develop
a skill that you didn't have before
i think you know
one of the things that's exciting about
learning a new skill is that the more
you do it not only the better you get
the more fun you have doing it it can be
hard to have a fun time when you're
learning the basics of
you know grammar in french or you're
learning how to ski and you're falling
over all the time um but the more you
actually do those things and you improve
your skills it actually becomes more fun
because you
gain confidence you gain um
you gain an ability to look back at what
you've accomplished and say you know
what
last week i was doing all the making all
these mistakes and now i actually get
this and now i can actually build upon
this skill and do more than i was able
to do last week